There's some big border drama
happening in South America right now.
The government of Venezuela
just had this ceremony
where they released this new map.
The map claims
all of this land;
land which is a part of the sovereign
country of Guyana.
Like they're claiming well over
half of Guyana's territory.
What is going on here?
Well, there are two answers.
The first one is the British.
Back in 1899,
the British and Venezuela
agreed on this border.
But Venezuela now
says that that was a biased decision
and that it was actually
just colonial shenanigans by the U.S.
and the U.K.
And that actually this is their land.
But the real answer here is oil.
In 2015,
they discovered a massive oil deposit
right off of the coast of Guyana.
They're making $1 billion
a year off this.
Venezuela wants this oil
and they think they have a claim
to all of this land.
And so they're going to fight for it.
Guyana,
obviously is not letting this happen.
They're going to fight about it.
It's going to be a thing.
I'm going to keep following it.
If you want to better understand
global politics, follow along for more.